the left knows that it is greatly to
their advantage
to increase racial consciousness for
their likely voter groups so you see
this all over the place elon university
is hosting a white caucus you might
think that the kkk is being revived
that's not the case the white caucus is
for white students to quote unpack
race and systemic oppression this is
what the email from elon university
reads a white caucus is a space for
white identifying individuals what's a
white identifying individual i guess
that could be like me right i'm sort of
swarthy
i've got this sicilian skin i guess i
could pass
for uh not a white guy but i i do i
identify as a white guy i guess
for white identifying individuals to
engage in conversations that unpack race
and systemic oppression
in this world wherever you're told that
white people are like the worst thing
ever and whiteness is a synonym for evil
who would choose to identify as a white
person i don't know
this is why by the way the the uh sort
of
public acceptability or even
encouragement of castigating whiteness
as a category
this is why you get the rachel dolezals
of the world this is why
it seems every month or so you find
another person who's you know
a gender theory professor or a critical
studies professor
who's been pretending to be hispanic or
black for their whole lives it turns out
they're just white people
because they're trying to identify as
another race because they've been told
that
being white is a very bad thing the
email goes on
white caucuses allow white identifying
allies to have these conversations in a
way
that does not burden or re-traumatize
people of color
re-traumatize white caucuses give white
people a space to learn about
and process their awareness of and
complicity in
unjust systems without harming their
friends of color
a lot of woke white liberals
believe this sort of thing it's very sad
it just is as sad if you were to grow up
actually i guess from the same ideology
if you were to grow up and be told
because i'm black
i cannot succeed i can't get ahead
the system is just out to get me people
who push this idea
are like ton heezy coates who is a very
wealthy
very famous very admired writer
why he's admired i have no idea but he's
admired by all the very fancy people he
wins
half a million dollar macarthur genius
grants and his message is basically the
whole system is rigged against black
people and they can't do anything
it's a horrible message to tell somebody
and it's
manifestly a lie right tonic easy codes
his life is evidence that that's a lie
in the same way how awful is it to tell
some white kid yeah man you're evil
you're awful
because of the color of your skin not
it's not we're not saying you're
oppressed
we're saying you're the oppressor you're
just a vile vicious evil person
and there's no way you can ever fix it
because you are
white you know you participate in this
thing called whiteness which has become
a synonym for evil that's a horrible
thing to tell kids
i don't know i guess i guess i'm immune
to
to what liberals might call white guilt
you know i don't feel
guilt because of my skin color i don't
feel
pride you know racial pride i don't
don't really take
glory or shame in the color of my skin
but increasingly
this is what we're told to do it's not
just at elon university purdue
university
was just proposing a mandatory class
in anti-racist thought what is
anti-racist thought
it's racist thought i know isn't that
ironic the purdue musical organizations
announced in january its members would
be required to complete six classes
on anti-racist thought this includes
white privilege
white supremacy white fragility
and white saviorism and how to be a
better ally this according to emails
that were
seen by the washington free beacon they
have backed off of this
since the emails came out these these
courses would have been taught by
well-known con artists ibram kindy
and robyn d'angelo they were supposed to
start this month
they've now been postponed this is
purdue produced a pretty conservative
university
purdue is run by mitch daniels former
republican governor of indiana
conservative guy very intelligent
is a keen understanding of education
even he
is being forced to adopt in some ways
this vicious
vile bigoted sort of stuff
it's sort of trite at this point to even
say it it's glib to say so i don't even
want to but to say
imagine if there were a course called
black privilege or black supremacy or
black fragility oh my god could you
imagine
but that's not the way it works because
as
actually as our as our friend told us
henry knox at the top of the show my
favorite comment yesterday when
victimhood is currency there's going to
be a lot of counterfeiters
when victimhood becomes the currency of
a society then victimhood is actually
going to become a privilege and people
are going to claim victimhood as best
they can if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
[Music]
you